dust from space
constantly falls from the sky
10 000 tons a year we call this material
cosmegnust and it is everywhere
it is on the streets in our homes
on the roofs of our houses and even
on our clothes cosmic dust particles
are just rocks simply very small rocks
and all rocks tell a story they record
the events that have happened to them
over their history and they record the
nature
of the environment in which they formed
and so we can read a history
of our solar system within
extraterrestrial dust
cosmic dust is incredible material and
it's
it's
really fascinating because it provides
us a story that meteorites
can't so meteorites are larger pieces of
rock
that come from outer space and several
thousand of those land
every year but billions of cosmic dust
particles land so they come from
everywhere
so meteorites provide us with a lot of
information
about a few different types of objects
in the solar system
cosmic dust samples them all and
provides a little bit of information
about each to micrometeorites or cosmic
dust
mainly comes from asteroids which is the
rocky and metallic
debris that lies mainly between the
orbits of
mars and jupiter so if we were to follow
the life
of a micrometeorite it would start in
the early solar system four and a half
billion years ago
when the asteroid formed that asteroid
would then
orbit the sun for billions of years
until one day fairly recently
a collision would occur and debris would
be produced from the asteroid including
lots of dust particles
and on being released into space
sunlight
just photons from the sun are enough to
slow that particle down in its orbit
making it spiral inwards towards the sun
and this particular micrometeorites it
finds itself on a collision course with
our planet
on encountering the earth's atmosphere
it falls towards the earth at a
tremendous speed
11.2 kilometers per second and the
friction with the air at these
tremendous speeds melts it to produce
our magma droplets it reacts with our
atmosphere changing as it does so
until finally it gently falls down to
the surface of the earth
just waiting for us to find it
although you can find cosmic dust
everywhere
there are certain places it's easier to
find whether it's in higher abundance
the very best place on earth is
antarctica
and that's where i go to get my dust the
reason
that the antarctic is so good for cosmic
dust
is that there is no water there now if
you think about antarctica you think
about all that ice and snow surely
that's water but to alter rocks
ice has to be liquid water so antarctica
is the driest desert on earth so
meteorites and cosmic dust
survive for millions of years and this
is from
a rocky area in antarctica called a
moraine
and contained in this dust about one in
in every 10 10 particles
is a cosmic dust particle so i search
this under
a microscope and by hand pick these
tiny particles and separate them you
know it's like meditation i am thinking
of nothing else my interest in in
extraterrestrial dust really came from
geology
and really my interest in science in
general came from art
i really like drawing and the only other
subject that i got to do these things
apart from art was geology so i actually
remember the moment where i
where i first went geology is for me and
that was
we we did a little field trip to the
beach
and i learned for the first time that i
could look at rocks
and i could read this detective story i
could see the
evidence for myself and i could work out
things that have happened
hundreds of millions of years ago
cosmic dust helps us solve some of the
big
mysteries about the universe so for
example
how did our solar system form is our
solar system
typical of other planetary systems and
that matters
because we know of 4 000 other planetary
systems
are they like ours do they have planets
with life how common is life
in our universe micrometeorites being
samples of asteroids and comets
provide us with evidence about the
materials
from which our solar system formed so
they can include tiny little mineral
grains
that condensed in the atmospheres of
giant stars
and unlike astronomy which which looks
at things from a distance
these are real solid mineral grains that
we can study in the laboratory
and they underpin a lot of our knowledge
of what goes on
in stars and what goes on in stars
controls the universe